donc ça c'est le champion le plus
dangereux le calice de la mort un
champignon responsable de 90 % des cas
d'empoisonnement à ne pas confondre avec
les autres espèces de la famille des
amanites une variété comestibles oui il
ya des amanites comestibles tout à fait
il ya des mecs qui sont comestibles qui
sont bonnes mais pas il y en a certains
qui sont très dangereuses même donc les
amanites s'est mélangé il ya des très
dangereuse des très bonnes
cette promenade organisée par
l'association des naturalistes des
yvelines permet de découvrir plusieurs
types de champignons spécialiste en
mycologie jérôme à faire reconnaît
conseil et explique les caractéristiques
des découvertes très jolie verdad pas
courant de champion verbales comme ça le
clip possible anisé alizés ça c'est
comme cible d'abord j'ai appris qu'il y
avait beaucoup plus de champignons non
comestibles que de champignons
comestibles
la preuve en est mon panier qui n'a qui
n'a je crois aucun champignons
comestibles ou si ce n'est des
champignons qui n'ont aucun intérêt
gustatif
moi je connais essentiellement les cèpes
et les volets dont je m'aventure
rarement sur autre chose
je connais les girolles mais paris si on
n'a pas les pieds de mouton mais il y en
a pas beaucoup non plus alors j'ai
appris beaucoup de choses sur les
champignons c'est qu'ils étaient
comestibles et pas comment les
reconnaître également à ya des
champignons très bon qui sont faciles à
reconnaître
l'acteur beau les russules différents
champignons avec beaucoup plus d'espèces
toxiques comestibles plusieurs
explications à ce phénomène
il ya deux raisons il ya une raison
c'est qu'il ya une grande poussée de cep
doit pas très longtemps et que la
poussée fini et donc ne va plus
deuxième raison on est quand même dans
une zone très proche de ville et qu'il
ya beaucoup de ramasseurs de champignons
qui ne viennent que pour ramasser les
champignons comestibles et qui vident un
peu les forêts prochaine chasse aux
champignons ce samedi 28 octobre à lille
de loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]